i'm working on my first album right now
it's coming out this year really excited
about the album
um with my music i like to push sonic
boundaries i like to try new things i
feel like
if i'm making music
and it sounds exactly like
what my predecessor has made there's
literally no points in me making music
so i like to yeah i always like to
to do something extra you know do
something different and to just make a
vibe that people can feel you know
because afrobeats is very
rhythm centric you know but my style of
afrobeats which i call emo afrobeats is
like
it's heavier on the rhythm but it's like
also heavy on the emotions too and the
vibes because like i want people to feel
stuff when they listen to me nemo
afrobeats yeah i like that
did you ever listen to like emo music
and absolutely like what would we
consider emo music because i think i'm
from a different generation than you
quite possibly
like out here there's like rock bands
that we consider emo like uh
i really like paramore i feel like they
have that's emo yeah yeah yeah yeah more
is incredible yeah heavy with power
moore's music i think
that's literally my favorite band
they're incredible you know um i also
used to listen to lots of juice world
juice rolls
triple x
that's a memo [ __ ] yeah so like this
this is literally my stomach that's a
nemo wrap for sure
and it's like my favorite you know i
listen to triple x like an unhealthy
amount of times you know
when you listen to like because i always
feel like um
you can't help but be influenced when
you're a fan of somebody like that like
would you consider yourself to be
influenced by someone like x who who was
here for such a short amount of time but
his music had such a big impact i would
say a little bit yeah cause
i don't know because he's a pisces and
i'm a i'm a pisces moon
so i don't know i feel like i connect
with his music on a crazy level